here with reaction all of its former
speaker of the house fox news
contributor
newt gingrich you know you've dealt with
you weren't even speaker and
you became the gingrich that stole
christmas
well look i i think you just have to
accept that the
news media most of it is going to be on
the left they're going to be very
vicious to republicans
uh as desantis continues to emerge as
one of the best governors in the country
he'll he'll get more of this treatment
but the american public's pretty smart
and they see through all that uh when
time had me
uh as uh scrooge with tiny tim's broken
crutch
on the cover of time but that actually
signaled
to our voters was oh gingrich is for
welfare reform
so that part doesn't bother me i think
the most troubling thing and
i'm doing two podcasts uh at
gingrich 360 one tomorrow and then or
one on wednesday one on thursday about
this whole georgia situation
the one on thursday really grew out of
our research
and i came to realize that joe biden has
a history
going back at least to the bork
nomination under ronald reagan
of smearing and lying and going after
people in vicious personal ways
again with clarence thomas in the bush
administration
and now of course with this most recent
thing where
when you're a liberal democrat and the
washington post gives you
four pinocchios because you lied so
thoroughly
and then two nights later he goes on
espn
and he lies again and it's really an
amazing story
about sort of a lynch mob attitude
trying to
attack georgia when in fact the georgia
bill is
more open more reforms longer voting
hours
the things set about are just plain lies
for example
you wouldn't be able to give people
water that's just not true
the bill says that the poll officials
might be
watching but you can't have other
campaigners do it
so they want an interesting one they
want no voter id
no signature verification and everybody
gets to
registered immediately and more mail-in
ballots
not being checked if that happens what
happens to voting
well look first of all i always describe
h.r one as the corrupt politicians act
uh it is and if you measure hr1 against
the georgia bill
you'll find that on every specific item
the american people favor the georgia
bill
over hr1 because hr1 is a power grab
by left-wing democrats that says we
don't have to know who you are
we don't have to prove you have a right
to vote you could be an illegal
immigrant
you could be somebody who's voted five
times we're willing to have
people like the service employees union
go into nursing homes
pick up all the ballots and then they
decide which ballots they're going to
vote i mean hr1 is a nightmare of
political corruption dishonesty in a
stolen election
mr speaker thank you for being with us